estos camilleros ucranianos llevan a un
soldado herido está siendo tratado Con
urgencia aquí los heridos se pueden
contar por docenas
los más graves son operados directamente
estábamos en una trinchera cuando la
artillería empezó a apuntarnos era un
lanzagranadas automático creo
atacados redoblan sus esfuerzos
los que pueden hacerlo disfrutan de un
momento de respiro
trojo estaba
últimamente se ha vuelto más peligroso
porque los combates están cada vez más
cerca pero seguimos trabajando como
antes
Se desconoce el número de muertos y
heridos de ambos bandos el frente de 40
kilómetros de badmud es ahora el
principal objetivo de la artillería rusa
en Ucrania
desde este verano se ha concentrado en
esta ciudad del Don vast en busca de la
Victoria tras las derrotas contra el
ejército ucraniano en el sur sin embargo
según la inteligencia estadounidense la
intensidad de los combates en todo el
país ha bajado un poco en las últimas
semanas y la tendencia podría ser aún
más pronunciada
Esperamos que el conflicto se ralentice
en los próximos meses gran parte de los
combates que tienen lugar actualmente en
la zona de nietzk se han ralentizado
desde La retirada rusa de gerson
Oriental
Washington prevé una reanudación de las
contraofensivas rusas y ucranianas en la
próxima Primavera Aunque duda de la
capacidad de Moscú para mantener el
ritmo de reabastecimiento y equipamiento
que se necesitaría para entonces